hey guys I welcome to the upper goddamn
I'm gonna go from a 10 to a 4
hey guys and welcome to the other show
my name is Chris Kelly and this is Sarah
Schneider and we are the creators and
executive producers of the other two and
we are here talking about the pilot
episode one
yeah with Brooke and Kerri Helene and
drew what yes two weeks ago oh honey are
you doing okay yes I'm great I'm Way
better than I was before
no offense Lance what we always said
that Kari felt like us in our 20s and
Brooke feels like us currently when
we're wasted the alarming part is that
is how I talk normally sober so what a
compliment I feel like while we were
shooting you were like this is who I am
I feel embarrassed that this isn't I am
hurt no truly I would read scripts and
be like oh I think you wrote this
because I overshare I'm so sorry and it
was just like constantly being projected
at me
hi I'm Kari doback and I'm reading for
the role of man at party who smells fart
I guess people have only seen the pilot
at this point but I will say that it
gets rough and tough for you yeah it
gets really tough like I think you go on
like fun journeys and you as an actor
get humiliated at every turn yeah yeah
that's accurate there's something about
like my face that reads as sad it's like
this this so this makes sense
we'd have conversations where we were
like oh he cried in the last one so he
probably shouldn't care for at least two
more yeah yeah halfway through filming I
was like oh I I'm not doing comedy
it's a comedy on comedy central
Thursdays at 10:30 yeah I have seen one
dick in four years this summer I'm gonna
see 50 dicks ill no it's empowering well
I have been dating someone for a very
long time
and so and then after that relationship
ended I didn't go on a quest to see 50
dicks but I was kind of like I am reborn
like let's hang let's party and got to
two and then I married the second one
it really is another wedding that was my
embarrassing thing is I were I worked at
a restaurant an Italian restaurant on
the Upper West Side and it was me and
there was one other gay waiter and one
night my boss literally pulled me aside
and was like can you go get the other
one wanted you both to know last night
at my home my wife and I watched
Brokeback Mountain I didn't like it but
I watched it saying thank you is it bad
that I sort of think about that and I'm
like oh
it was sweet adjacent is he gonna be
like legit famous no there's no way yeah
no I mean how big could he really get
[Music]
well there's the other three in my
family my scissors audition for this
show called American Juniors which was a
spinoff of American Idol the year after
Kelly Clarkson won and one of them made
it on the show yeah and they flew our
whole redneck family to LA and as soon
as I got there I like went to Melrose
and I like bought a white belt and a Von
Dutch hat and so you were like I'm gonna
be on TV get me to a store to buy a
white belt exactly and we sat on the
side of the stage and then they would
like cut to us and they'd be like tar
VORs what do you think and we'd be like
we loved it
so did people start knowing you from the
show because you were always decided
well yeah you're over to the side and
like when you leave the studio people
would be like Kaitlyn's brother that's
okay I would I was like basically at the
time I was like you can do nothing and
people will sort of scream your name I
love Los Angeles oh yeah so did you that
made your brain be like I love this yeah
you weren't embarrassed or like oh no
the cool parts of Carrie like where he's
like I don't want this I'm better than
this I did not have it was like oh man
this is I don't know what I guess maybe
I could be Ryan Seacrest oh that was
interesting from Georgia I was like look
what secrets did buckle up girls there's
a sexy new singer in town and guess what
he just turned 13 pace wonder who lays
chase who plays the pop phenom is not
here but I guess let's talk about him
behind his back yeah yeah that is a
whole other part of the show which is
yeah us for in comparison to that yeah
like a young right out the gate I am
talented and know what I like and know
what I do know what my brand is know
what my deal is
yeah that's I found him on the internet
we found him on music which is like an
app I'm like I can't even talk you could
I don't know I was there at some
audition he brought you guys to the
callbacks yeah oh my god came in and was
just like they were like case what do
you been up to and he was like I just
been rising and grindin know yeah the
grind
which is what I think Ken Marino
Streeter says in the pilot and then we
have people say like so many things that
case says in real life yeah we're like
can we use this literally what do we say
secrets would know how to wrap it up VC
crest rapid get us out of here
all right guys was there it was back
there it was you loved it it's fun and
make sure to tune in later for house
[Laughter]
you